everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm and today we are in round 2
of our coverage of the 2016 World Chess
Championship between Magnus cross and
the reigning champion in the Challenger
Sarah gave Hokkien in game 1 we did have
a draw Magnus Carlsen did have the white
pieces trying out the d4 trump aus key
opening with Bishop to g5 didn't go as I
think he planned a pretty draws game
throughout no one even really tried to
do much in my opinion game 2 we have
certainly a Kodiak and playing the white
pieces trying to get out in front of his
opponent we have a 12 game match going
on over the next few weeks so anytime
you can get a victory especially with
the white pieces it is very very
important so Sergei starts out with pawn
to e4 this is kind of what we expected
from Carlsen yesterday pawn to e5 Knight
f3 knight c6 Bishop b5 getting into the
right Lopez and then pawn to a6 and this
is somewhat odd from Magnus Carlsen he
pretty much always plays Knight to f6 in
fact most of the top players are playing
this Birdland offense a lot more but
Magnus Carlsen even going back to the
World Championships against Vishy Anand
he really favors that Knight to f6
Berlin defense so kind of odd to see him
play more of a classical Morphy defense
with the pawn to a6
after Bishop to a4 plays Knight to f6
and then castle on the King side and
from here Magnus Carlsen has a lot of
different options he could go with more
of an open defense with Knight taking on
e4
I could always play more of a Russian
defense with I I think it'd be somewhat
fitting considering his opponents
Russian pawn to d6 could always play
more of an archangel defense with pawn
to b5 but he apps for just kind of the
closed defense and that's Bishop to e7
says I'm not gonna do too much I'm gonna
continue my developing castle on the
Kings side and then continue from there
and then pawn to d3 and this is really
the first time that we've seen a move
that's kind of outside the ordinary for
what it has lots of different options
here you could have kind of a delayed
exchange here on c6 Knight to c3 is what
I usually end up playing this particular
spot or if you want to just play a
little bit more
have pawn to d4 just trying to blow up
the center of the board here is white
since you do have a small tempo
advantage but decides to play pawn to d3
just solidify the Ponte but it's not
super aggressive though but if you kind
of look back
Sergei actually played this just a few
months ago in the Chess Olympiad so he's
familiar with this opening this
particular variation although we don't
see it too often it does come up in his
repertoire so continues with pawn to b5
from magnus carlsen bishop back here b3
pawn to d6 just solidifying this pawn
chain also opening up the door for the
light square bishop be involved as
needed pawn to 8/3 castle on the Kings
side at Knight to c3 both sides just
continuing the development Knight to a5
attacking the bishop and the bishop
coming back here to a2 this is kind of
something Bobby Fischer used to do a lot
bringing his bishop over here to c4 and
then eventually bring it back here to a2
slightly different variation getting
into the right Lopez but same kind of
concept bringing the bishop back here to
a2 still attacking this long diagonal a
with the pawns here on e5 and e6 that
allows this LightSquared bishop to be
very very important in the attack Magnus
Carlsen is not really having that so he
plays Bishop here to e6 just trying to
stop that attack right now sighs let's
go ahead and exchange on board if you
want to decide not to instead plays pawn
to d4 and I like that I don't really
like playing bishop takes on e6 because
then the pottery captures yes black has
double pawns here anytime you have
double pawns in the center of the board
it's not as bad especially if you have
kind of support here from your D pawn as
well and then you open up a semi-open
file on the F file for this rook to
really get involved and really start to
attack your opponent's King side so all
in all I don't recommend playing you
know just bishop takes here on e6 but it
does look like this light to her bishop
is gonna have to fall for start to get a
cardiac in so pawn to d4 trying to
strike the cert of the board and then we
do see an exchange on board with the
bishops and then the rook ticking here
on a two Magnus Carlsen rook over to e8
just getting his rook a little more
centralized into the game rook back here
to a1 it's not doing anything here on a
two so it just brings it back to a one
night to see for just kind of a
transitional move
it's not really attacking too much right
now Sergei has the opportunity just to
play pawn to b3 that's probably what I
would do on board I think it's easy just
to go and kick your opponent back right
here Knight back b6
you can play Bishop to e3 if you want to
or if you're worried about this Knight
to g4 that's gonna just kick your bishop
back here to d2 you can always play a
pawn to h3 here you can play rook here
to e1 as a first move but I'm just going
to play that that pawn to be through we
end up saying this a little bit later
but decides to go and play rook to e1
first rook to c8 just centralizing a
little bit more pawn to h3 and then
Magnus Carlsen waiting for a little bit
and like pawn to h6 so both sides just
trying to block off some of these
critical squares over here g4 Square
from whites of the knight can get
involved to the action and this pawn
here on h6 blocking off the square here
on g5 so that I can't get into the
action so both these Knights really just
now protecting and controlling the
center of the board
Ponta the b3 kicking the knight back
Knight back here to be 6 and then Bishop
to b2 so did have the option of get
involved but decided since this pawn
here on h6 it's not going to be doing
too much pond III not as exciting
knowing that it's not going to be coming
here to f4 or g 5 anytime soon so it
says i'm gonna go ahead and start
gearing up for the center of the board
if we do see some exchange on these dark
squares wants to go ahead and have his
dark squared bishop involved into that
action bishop back here to f8 Magnus
Carlsen is kind of thinking about the
same thing so wants to make sure his
rook has evolved Rick here to 8 e8 rook
on e8 protecting this dark square bishop
right here our dark square here on e5
after the exchange we see pawn to a4 and
a lot of people in this particular
situation thought this Sergei should go
ahead and just take with his queen so
Queen takes on d8 now I think it's worth
a look how this particular variation
would end up not exactly sure but rook
take from c8 to d8 wants to make sure he
doesn't take with this rook because then
you can just go ahead and take that pawn
right here on e5 but after this rook
takes all of a sudden Knight to a 2
opening up the door for this dark
squared Bishop here on b2 to attack this
pawn
does have the other night here so maybe
Knight over here
seven protecting but does kind of block
this rook off from the action and then
the brook over here to d1 getting into
this open file to try to control that as
much as possible you know it's kind of
tough you have this night over here on a
two that's not going to be involved into
the action anytime soon
it's not clear that you have a super
strong attack even this bishop right
here still kind of tied down to this
pawn on eight eight three so at the
other day certainly I kind of looked at
this and said I'm gonna go a different
route I see an advantage here with pawn
to a4 so continues with pawn to a4 pawn
to c6 just solidifying this pawn chain a
little bit and also controlling this
square here on d5 still a very important
square in the center of the board and
then we start to see any exchange on
board so certainly I says okay let's go
ahead and exchange off Queens and then
pawn takes on b5 pawn recaptures Knight
to e2 Bishop down here to b4 and Magnus
Carlsen had a few options here I think
as soon as I see night down here on e 2
this does kind of block this rook here
on e1 from protecting this pawn on e4 I
would just immediately take here on e4 I
recognize that the bishop could take
here on e5 that does kind of blow up the
central pawns but then Knight down here
to d2 this just starts to put a lot of
pressure on my opponent you now have a
very active rook controlling this Knight
right here you know we're really not
gonna see take right here because then
all of a sudden Magnus Carlsen is
attacking the second-ranked that's not
what you want your opponent to be doing
but at the end of the day Magnus Carlsen
really like to go ahead and get his dark
squared Bishop involved a little bit
sooner so Bishop here too before Bishop
here to c3 Magnus Carlsen decide so
let's go ahead and exchange those off on
board and they takes on c3 Knight over
here to a d7 protecting this pawn here
on e5 and then rook up here to a6 rook
here to c8 so Magnus Carlsen is
definitely in a defense mode not really
trying to attack any of Sirte gaze
pieces at all upon up here to be four
look down here he's 6 more defensive
trying to eye down make sure nothing
happens with these pawns on board Luke
over here be one pawn here to c5 opening
up
door says hey if you want to go ahead
and exchange on board that's fine with
me
I'll take care now keep in my madness
Crossin does have double pawns here
although it is gonna be somewhat
difficult to go ahead and take advantage
of this if you are Saratoga County akan
Knight takes on d5 pawn recaptures on b4
after the rook takes rook down here to
see to getting on the second rank that
up here a d6 and then rook down here see
one and this is kind of the end of the
game King up here h2 rook to c2
attacking the pawn here on f2 kind of
forcing the King to come back here - do
you want to protect this in this
particular spot they did decide to draw
the game I actually think they may have
drawn the game a little bit earlier but
they do need to get to 30 moves in this
tournament and so after 33 moves they
decided to go ahead and draw the game
afterwards even kind of ask some of the
players that it wasn't the most exciting
no one really went for anything too
crazy as we talked about in the first
game they've had months and months of
preparation especially that that first
game I think it's so important to just
psychologically get a big win under your
belt I thought we would just see some
haymakers out there some lines and some
openings we never even really seen
played at a high level in a long time
although these players have come out of
the gate and haven't played anything
crazy at all and magnus carlsen kind of
responded to this question said hey you
know every game is not gonna be
fireworks we do have 12 games that we're
gonna be playing so be patient games
definitely will be exciting but this one
not the most exciting and I think any
any chess fan even the players
themselves recognize that not much was
going on still very very high level
chess you know you just don't see this
variation in the right Lopez very often
I think both players played extremely
well they didn't get out of line it into
it do anything too crazy so all-in-all
we're tied up both players have a full
points getting half a point in each of
the games for its high so we will take a
day off in the next day and then we will
come back on Monday for Game three and -
cross one will have the white pieces so
everyone thanks for watching following
along with the coverage over the next
few weeks enjoy the video and I will see
y'all in the next one
thanks again for watching